Hey good morning everyone like you heard
I came down from Boston yesterday so I
missed the tutorials but had a nice a
train ride finished up some of the
slides for this so the talk I'm giving
today is sell cron by air flow modern
data pipelines and Finance
so I myself am a site reliability
engineer at quant opions so I'm not
someone handling the finance side or
even the data science side of things I
actually work on the infrastructure and
the systems but I've done that at other
data rolls before so I did that the
Harvard Center for brain science I've
done some other stuff as well as sort of
jumped all over the map I like variety
so it's really good job for me because
it means I get to support what everyone
else in the company is doing and learn a
little bit about a bunch of different
technologies but personally I actually
came from a background of academia and
public policy so I did work that was
pretty similar to like modern data
science work back then and then shifted
into being more of a back-end person so
again as a first disclaimer I'm an SRE
professional I can tell you all about
UNIX or networks I can't tell you about
financial regulation so give you that
disclaimer opinions expressed in this
presentation are my own and not quant
opions even though I'm talking about
what quanto peon does and this
presentation is not investment advice
why do I say it's not investment advice
well there's actually restrictions on
who can give you investment advice and
as it turns out the SEC takes this
extremely seriously unlike some people
all right now just as a show of hands
how many folks have heard of quant opium
before oh yeah cool cool it's always
about glad to see some fans in the
audience just I kind of recap what we do
because I did see some people who didn't
raise a hand we provide a lot of
education about how to use either Python
for finance or if you already know
Python how to actually learn the
financial concepts to build models
against essentially the stock market we
want anyone in the world to be able to
pursue quantitative finance to do it in
a browser to not have to do Python
dependency management to get up and
running so it's all Jupiter based but
it's not just technology it's also the
combination of the education that we do
and the data that we provide on the
platform so it's really easy to get
basic financial data but if you want to
have a high-performing algorithm on the
stock market it needs to be cleaned data
it needs to be more up-to-date reliable
you need types of data that aren't
available to consumers for free so you
know back in the days people would do
like you know your Yahoo Finance data
and like base an algorithm off of that
if you want to get better results on
that you really do need clean data and
that's part of the value proposition
that quanto peein is providing okay so
why would you actually write an
algorithm with Kanto being other than
that it's fun for some people well we
also provide allocation so if your
algorithm performs well on quanto peein
will actually sign something with you to
allow us to invest money in it and give
you a share of that money so effectively
if you don't have the capital but you do
have the skills on token is a really
great value proposition for you now
quanto bean has recently partnered with
fact set which is a new data provider
that we've added we have a larger
partnership with they're one of the
largest financial data providers in the
world so it's really hugely expanding
the scope of the types of data that we
have on the platform for instance we've
started adding international markets
previously we just had US equities now
we have several markets with many more
coming soon we also recently added the
ability to bring your own data to the
quantou peein platform it's self-serve
data what this means is you can not only
just write an algorithm on quanto peein
but you can every night import the
latest data perhaps you have some model
that you're training yourself off of
quanto bian you have some interesting
web scraping that you're doing things
that you can't do within the quanto peon
algorithm api you can still upload and
integrate with your algorithms so why am
i talking about this stuff because as an
SRE it's my job to support all that you
know if you have a nightly data pipeline
it needs to you actually run and if
there's a problem with it someone needs
to get woken up and to fix it at quanto
peein that's people on the SRA team so
what is an SRE it's a site reliability
engineer and
that means that I'm working on any kind
of problem that would affect the
reliability of our ability to develop
deploy or operate services so yes that
means actually running the servers but
it also means logging monitoring build
systems consulting on initial
architecture like deciding which
database we're going to use or where
we're going to store files so it's a mix
of traditional operations work and
something closer to data engineering
like actually understanding the domain
that you're working in the way that we
do teams at quanto pian is that every
SOA gets attached to one of our
development teams the team that I'm
attached to is the Black team which does
a lot of our data infrastructure
particularly for the investment side of
the house squanto pian is actually
placing trades we have an execution
engine so we need to have all of that
infrastructure set up reliably and it's
a little different from the nightly work
that we do to provide free data on the
platform because it's actually
interfacing with a lot of external
vendors and placing trades and sending
it to them also because of that because
it's actually trying to turn a profit we
have a data science element to this and
we take a lot of the data science stuff
done by other teams and try to
productize it so we do feel comfortable
backing with money so for the rest of
the presentation we talk about our data
pipelines when I say community data I'm
talking about what you see if you make a
quant OB an account and log in so the
data that you can use in your algorithms
that you can start building models based
off of and this isn't just like we
download some stuff and we expose it to
you we actually do our own processing to
make it perform it aware of look-ahead
bias we have our own file formats that
we use for handling this we also produce
our own portfolio risk model something
traditionally only available to large
institutions but we've made it available
to the whole community but we're a
start-up we're like any other modern
startup a lot of the data work we do is
just everywhere in the company
everywhere in the company needs to do
data work to be an effective startup so
that means that we have just analytics
data who's using what features where are
people coming from where are they in the
acquisition process
and we also do analytics on our own
performance so those trades that we
place we need to understand did they go
as expected what was the profit at loss
there is there something we can do to
manage risk better we also have a team
dedicated to just onboarding like new
new experimental ideas data science
projects new data sets new partner
integrations so there's a lot of
exploratory work that happens around
data so we really really drip
data-driven company but we're also a
company that has data as part of our
core domain so we get it on kind of both
sides there now as you know more data
more problems and it was actually around
this time last year that I got tasked
with improving our ETL processes so we
had some initial set of criteria just
sort of describing the problem and I did
some initial research into what our
problems really were and how we might go
about fixing them one of the problems
that we faced is that we had really high
need for reliability because if you have
trading infrastructure you're trading an
investor's money you have a lot of legal
requirements on how you place those
trades you have a lot of requirements on
reporting and compliance so it's not
just like you know you place the trades
and that's it
you have to do work before you can place
the trades you have to reliably execute
the trade and then you have to do
follow-up work to do the accounting for
that and to attribute profit to that we
did actually operate at really high
reliability before this project but it
was coming at a very high human cost
we were frequently getting paged having
to do things manually it was not a
sustainable way to do development not in
the sense that it was you know it wasn't
an insurmountable problem for the team
but it was affecting the speed that
which we could develop new features and
that's actually a huge problem when
you're interfacing with a market it's
all about agility because alpha the
profit you find in a market tends to
decline so even as it's important for a
startup to move fast startup that's
actually placing trades it's even more
crucial that you have the ability to
iterate
quickly and our high reliability was at
a point where it was dragging down our
velocity when really the two don't have
to move in opposite directions like that
it's possibly very fast and very
reliable of course you all know this
problem so I don't have to explain it as
much but yeah the even when you have a
large financial data vendor even if it's
not just data that you scraped yourself
they're they're just issues in it you
have to be able to account for that we
do have a lot of automated data checks
but sometimes they weren't getting run
except by manual effort or they weren't
picking up on some of the real world
issues that we had so we needed a system
that could cope with us
one of the main pain points of this
system is that it was based on Cron's
halves now if you're not like a sysadmin
type if you haven't heard of cron before
it's just a really simple scheduling
tool it runs things on a very regular
schedule so hourly or nightly or every
third day in the month of December or
something like that and it's great for
getting things running when you have
like one system that you're maintaining
yourself it's a very easy tool to use
but it's very limited when you start
talking about having dozens or hundreds
of these chrome tabs it's very limited
when you start talking about alternative
calendars and schedules it's very
limited when it comes to reporting so
it's a good tool to get up and running
fast but it's not a maintainable and
sustainable tool when you have a lot of
teams starting these scheduled jobs and
needing to understand the impact of
those jobs failing now because of some
of those problems with chrome tabs
because cron provides so little logic in
its scheduling system we actually had to
add a lot of additional scheduling logic
inside the scripts that we were calling
and that mean we had logic baked in
dozens of different places with slight
differences so became very hard to
understand our data ecosystem why things
were making scheduling decisions why
they thought they should run with this
flag on this day and a different flag on
another day so all this combines
together to create a bottleneck because
in any kind of finance company there's
tighter controls over who has access to
servers and who can deploy things
s-series became the bottleneck for
managing all this complexity and really
limited our ability to iterate quickly
so we wanted to fix our data pipelines
but before we could do that we need to
talk about the business goals that we
were trying to achieve and that would
help us pick out a system so of course
reliability was one of those major goals
we wanted to just not have these kinds
of problems we don't want jobs to fail
at all so that's the best way to not get
woken up if you just don't get paged
because the system is working but we
know that it's never going to be
perfectly reliable we base this off of
other people's data and they're always
going to be issues around having
external vendors even if we do
everything right one of our vendors
could still have an issue so we need to
be able to diagnose that quickly there's
this concept too called observability so
if you're familiar with the issues that
people in the ml space have been having
with like understanding why their models
make that decision well you actually run
into a lot of the same problems in a
very complex distributed live system
it's very hard to trace what was
producing data what data was available
at what time why your systems made
certain decisions so it's a lot of the
same goals of being able to trace that
through the entire system and understand
why your application made a decision and
as I mentioned velocity was a core goal
on this we wanted not just to take our
existing system and make it better but
we wanted a fundamentally new system
that made it easier to push changes very
quickly so it didn't need to be a
week-long effort to add one of these new
jobs something where you could just push
new code and if the tests passed it
would be running so that might sound
familiar some of these problems if
you're working in a data science
department you've probably encountered
some of them the answer is that most
companies are facing this type of
challenge the same way that most
companies are also facing challenges
adopting the ideas of DevOps once every
company starts needing to manage data
and run in the cloud they all start
having very similar-looking problems
that being said every company does have
some unique aspects and one for us at
quanto Qian is democratization what I
mean by that is we want decision-making
to be shared within the company we want
people to understand what everyone's
working on so we're very transparent but
about to the external community we want
everyone able to be involved in
quantitative finance but internally we
want all the teams to understand each
other we're not like traditional kind of
finance where you think of like very
siloed teams that are secretive about
how they're making profit we don't do
that in-house so we wanted something
where anyone could just send in a pull
request much more similar to open-source
development even though it's for
internal closed projects two other notes
here I just want to emphasize we're not
talking about solving big data in the
sense of like Hadoop clusters we're not
running off of huge amounts of log base
data we already had very well performing
file formats tailored towards finance
data we're not talking about streaming
financial data so this is not
high-frequency trading that's not the
space that we're in so we're talking
about batch nightly ETL jobs where the
jobs are of high complexity but they are
a very constrained data size and
schedule so it's more about managing the
organizational complexity of these
processes well we're all cloud based we
wanted to make sure that we could run
whatever tool we were running within our
own account and have ownership over it
we also want to make sure it was not an
ETL specific tool or a data pipeline
tool or a data warehousing tool the
reason being that on the SRE team we
have to take what are called
orchestration actions in response to
data
so by orchestration I mean starting up a
new cluster deploying code to existing
servers things that are not strictly
data tasks but that relate to new data
that's being published so we always want
to make sure the freshest data is on the
platform and sometimes you need to take
steps that aren't just as simple as
inserting records into a database or
pushing a file to s3 so some systems are
very locked into that mindset we also
knew that we wanted this to be a system
that was a directed acyclic graph it's
just the most natural representation for
a sequence of ordered tasks like this so
cron doesn't provide that at all all of
the times were just this runs at 9:05 we
think it's done in 10 minutes the next
one runs at 9:15 except we built in a
buffer so it actually runs at 9:20 yeah
once you have a hundred of those that
just doesn't work at all so that's
that's good for your first project it
was time for us to have something that
actually tracked dependency relation
oops that's what that looks like an
airflow by the way which is the tool we
did end up selecting we also needed
something that had real scheduling logic
this is what it just looks like for the
US exchanges and you can see they have
different holidays some of the holidays
are partial days not full holidays they
close and then reopen so there's
actually a lot of scheduling logic
complexity by the way every market is on
a different schedule sometimes there's
more than one market per country those
countries are in different time zones
some countries observe daylight savings
at different times this is like a huge
scheduling problem there's so much
complexity once you're starting to work
across you know ten countries 20
countries even more we needed a tool
that could actually express this in a
reasonable way
Python is actually pretty good at that
there's a lot of capabilities to do this
sort of thing in Python that's not true
of bash scripting so actually I also
have done work at a MRI lab in my case
the Harvard Center for brain science
this is what a brain MRI processing
pipeline looks like so these are all the
steps in the pipeline you can see they
fork and join and one of the interesting
things about that is that some of these
tasks could take like 24 hours to run
because you're working with like
3-dimensional float data at very high
resolution where you're talking about
like millimeter voxels and things like
that so what that means is it's very
expensive to recompute things so there's
a lot of use of more functional data
systems where you save every
intermediate art step in an architecture
like this and that's actually this kind
of process that we wanted to adopt with
our system we wanted a more functional
data pipeline system where rather than
one big instance that's really powerful
and it does a lot of on disk processing
and moves files from one location to
another we wanted checkpointing built in
at every step of the system so it would
upload the artifacts to in our case s3
and then if the step after that failed
we could rerun just from that step it's
a much more functional and immutable way
of thinking about data stating all these
put together for us that choice was
pretty obvious to
Apache airflow this project came out of
Airbnb that's why it's called airflow
and it's a really out-of-the-box tool
for doing a lot of this work air flow is
currently incubating so it's going to be
part of the overall Apache project soon
and it's on version 1.10 with version
2.0 coming fairly soon probably next
year you get a lot of the box with air
flow it's not a command line tool it's
actually got features for web interface
so you can see all of the executions of
your tasks whether they succeeded or
fail the schedule that they're happening
on the dependency relationships between
them and it's really got some great
observability features and some great
operational features it actually
understands the difference between the
person writing the model the person
viewing the logs from the model and the
person who's managing the cluster
administration and that's really great
from the perspective of an SRE I don't
actually know what a lot of the jobs
running on the airflow cluster are I
don't have deep knowledge of that code
but I do have a lot of knowledge of what
our overall nightly process should look
like because it's my job to keep that
running so it's a tool that's good
whether you're focused on one specific
task that it's your responsibility to
run or whether you're responsible for
the overall operations of the cluster it
also attracts a lot of execution data so
you get like night over night data on
how long casts are taking you can even
do alerting based on that so if I could
tasks you usually expect to take two
hours and it takes four you can actually
have it send you an email or in our case
a pager Duty notification so you find
out about that and can fix it another
really nice feature for for air flow
relative to a lot of a competition
if you've used things like pachyderm or
Luigi those seem like fine tools for a
single ml engineer but that's not the
use case that we have we need to put
things in production they need to run at
large scale they may need to keep
running when that team has moved on to
some other project so my team is all
about production izing things and
airflow is already a heavily
productionize distributed service it has
different classes of workers it has a
metadata database
it has its own task queue so it's not
something where you have to figure out
how you're gonna take an airflow client
and lift it up into the cloud it can be
cloud native from day one which is a
really appealing feature in this kind of
data processing system one final note
it's a Python project
I love Python I wouldn't be here if I
weren't a Python fan I actually have a
Python tattoo there got import this
right here okay so you've heard all
about why I like airflow let me show you
some code from it this is what we call
an operator so if you think back to a
dag it's a graph and what we call the
little dots and graphs are notes so an
operator is one node so it's like one
task that you're performing in the graph
this particular one is aware of trading
calendar holidays so it knows what the
holidays are for a particular markets
trading calendar and it knows not to
perform downstream actions on that day
so it's very simple it's just like a
Python function that you just write in a
more constrained framework style of code
and once you have these operators
written and by the way air flow comes
with dozens of these out of the box you
can actually chain them together using
the bit shift operator as a shorthand
and this was a super serious business
problem that we have we all subscribe to
a meal ordering service individually and
we need to put in our orders by 10:00
a.m. and we often were missing it
because we would get to work and forget
about it but we can't just order it
every day because we're closed on stock
market holidays and we get catered
lunches on Wednesday so we actually have
a complex set of business rules for when
to order lunch and that's what that
looks like when you put that in the UI
it's aware of which days or company
meetings or not it's aware of which days
or holidays and weekends
so it only sends an ACK here slack
notification when they're like actually
people in the office so that's what it
looks like it's like we have our own
little chat bot but it's not just a cron
schedule it's a schedule that's aware of
our domain so when we put stuff in air
flow for us there are a few
considerations one is if the cron job
has to be resilient or distributed
that's a plus for putting an airflow
another is that if it has any upstream
data dependencies or any downstream data
dependencies so either consumes or
produces it out
artifact that's a definite plus to
putting an airflow and the third item
there is that if we think anyone in the
company might want to extend this to add
their own logic maybe it's not an
official step but like they just want to
know when this data load finishes every
night or they want to restart their
development instance based on this data
availability that's also a candidate for
being an airflow
so if it's got even one of those things
it's a pretty good fit for airflow if
it's two or more of those criteria it's
a great fit for airflow so here's what
our nightly data load process looked
like when we started putting it in air
flow we would decide whether we traded
yesterday if we did we had some other
non airflow services that would be
producing data and we would wait for
them to complete and if they did
complete we would start queuing some
tasks downstream and while those tasks
queued successfully we would replace
some of our services as well as run the
nightly quanto peon contest where we
simulate your performance on the results
of the data from that day and that's
what that looks like in slack we get
some really cool notifications about
when things are running we have links
back to the UI so if I get paged at 2:00
a.m. or 3:00 a.m. it's easy to jump in
and understand what ran is intended and
what didn't run because it's not always
as simple as just oh something failed I
have to restart it sometimes it's like
oh this failed and this had an
undeclared dependency so I need to
actually go figure out everything that
ran using the corrupt version of data
and roll everything back and then fix it
and then start again right those are the
kinds of data problems you have when
you're in a production environment and
having it on a linear list like this but
still with a graph representation makes
it really easy to debug so this is
really successful actually so that's v2
and you can see it just kind of keeps
growing as we add more stuff to it with
that factset data partnership it
actually now looks like this
so we added HR Pacific and EU as a data
ingestion steps there and as we start
linking more of these types of data to
each other as we start running on more
calendars this dag will just grow and
grow one other example I wanted to talk
about from an operational side it's one
of our existing services called file
mover
faul mover is just like a data transfer
service it knows how to login on FTP and
SFTP and well that's basically all
anyone in finance uses file mover breaks
all the time I don't mean that because
like file mover is bad the reason it
breaks is because FTP servers go down
the files we expect aren't there they
didn't get published that day they were
operating on a different calendar than
we were the file got published late so
it did eventually show up basically we
have this brittle chrome tab based
system for data transfers and it was
missing a lot we were getting paged
almost every day on average and because
I had chrome tabs we couldn't run this
service at certain times of day to ship
it because the service was running on a
single instance so it wasn't a very
reliable system and that's why it caused
so many pages so we hired an SRE intern
over the summer Danny who actually is
going to be working with us on an
ongoing basis and because we tackled as
the summer project switching this
existing service to air flow she was
actually able to merge like 70 PRS over
the course of one summer as an intern
coming into this without prior knowledge
of either finance or of like SRA
so this incredible productivity tool
being able to port this existing system
to air flow basically over the course of
a summer and they do it in an
evolutionary way where we could move
jobs over one at a time as we got more
confidence with the air flow system so
that's what that looks like now it's the
same thing that was here everything runs
at about the same time but instead of a
flat time based representation we now
have a graph based representation we can
understand where the dependencies
actually are so that's what that looks
like to have that gradual rollout we
have you know a task that doesn't exist
so it's that white icon also there's
lots of holidays that's whenever you see
like an irregular pink line those are
tasks getting skipped so like three days
in a row is like Saturday Sunday and a
Monday holiday okay so the last example
that I want to talk about is something
that's really new for us it's what I
have been working on over the past three
months or so we're calling at the quanto
P and alpha model it's
way to dramatically increase the number
of algorithms that we're including in
our community allocations basically
every night we're running this data
science process on the result of
community algorithms I can't talk about
much of the details about how we're
doing it but it's all based on air flow
and kubernetes so essentially each one
of these steps is a containerized Python
process that we're using air flow to
schedule and link all the dependencies
between and then at the end of each of
those steps we upload those artifacts
and that's actually been immensely
successful for us because we built this
entire project from day one running on
air flow this wasn't like we had some
existing project and forklifted it into
air flow like we were talking about with
file mover we were able to use air flow
strengths from the beginning and one of
the real strengths here is that the team
who's implementing this data science
work has a real production cluster that
runs exactly the same as our nightly
data loads for running something that's
still in development every time they
make some change they can push out a new
container they can log into the web
interface and rerun tasks they can
understand and get their own failure
notifications so this doesn't go to sre
if it fails it goes to the team that is
responsible for pushing out all this
code it's like we built this platform
for them and it's up to them to make the
most of that platform so I really love
the combination of air flow and
kubernetes if you haven't heard of
kubernetes by the way it's a cluster
scheduling tool that came out of Google
it's sort of like docker but taking
those containers and running them in the
cloud at a very large scale so you can
send as many containers as you want to
and it will just figure out what
machines to start or where to put those
containers you as a developer don't have
to think about it at all so we're a year
into adopting kubernetes at mon-sol
peein and we're also about a year into
adopting air flow and that you really
worked well together because air flow
has some problems around dependency
management it's a Python process and a
lot of the dag code that you write and a
lot of the tasks code is also running in
Python so what does that mean if Cort
air flow and it has a different Python
dependency need then your operator does
it actually sucks to manage and
kubernetes on the other hand it uses
container so you just package up all
your
into a container and ship it no
dependency problems but it doesn't have
any concept of dependent scheduling it
has a highly available resilient cron
job system but you can't have cron jobs
trigger other cron jobs in any useful
way so what do you get when you put them
together you have the ability to write
Python code for your data science
project bake it into a container and
schedule it on highly resilient back-end
using more Python code so all you have
to do as a consumer of this is write a
lot of Python and you're pretty good at
that
I hear so quanto bian really loves
airflow it's seen a lot of adoption for
something that was basically like a
one-person project to get this up and
running we have a lot of our systems
that are reliant on at this point
if you're in the position of you think
that the code you're writing is going to
be run in the real world on a production
system night over night
I think airflow is a really strong
candidate for that if it meets the
criteria that I discussed earlier so I
love airflow but you don't have to trust
me because are my coworkers some
screenshots of what they've had to say
about it in slack so this this happens a
lot right someone will move something
into airflow someone else won't even
know that that was an airflow until
something breaks and it's suddenly much
easier to fix it so I feel a little
obligated we are hiring for the SRE team
that I'm on as well as for software
engineers if you're interested you can
come talk to me how am i doing on time
for this one
eight minutes great so I want to talk a
little bit about future development as
well because airflow gets you a lot out
of the box it does have some warts to it
some things that it's missing actually
Jeremiah who is one of the speakers
today is going to be giving a talk on
prefect which is the tool that he's been
working on based on his very lengthy
experience with air flow that addresses
some of these problems but there's also
efforts to address some of these
problems in air flow itself one that I'm
passionate about as someone who gets
woken up when air flow fails is I want
enhanced SLA service level agreements
airflow has a feature for this where it
can warn you if a task takes too long or
doesn't start at the expected time
I actually have a pretty lengthy PR to
revamp this and in general improve the
operational features for people like me
to administrate airflow clusters one
thing that I think is really relevant to
developers is that there's a lot of
opportunity to have unit tests for
airflow DAGs directed acyclic graphs
because in a normal test suite you're
testing every step in isolation you want
to make sure that things published the
right place that they load their config
file properly you should totally write
unit tests it's great but as someone who
runs this kind of thing in the real
world
unit tests don't solve the hardest
problems in data science figuring out
where the data is stored making sure
that a schema change and one producer
doesn't affect consumers downstream it's
very hard to unit test that but you
already have a structured representation
of your graph you know what tasks that's
trying to execute I think there's a lot
of potential here to base this on
historical data to be able to run tests
that simulate failure conditions like
what would happen if this task failed
and had to retry would we still meet our
nightly goal deadlines what happens if
we have a 95th percentile slowdown what
if it's a 99th percentile slowdown how
does that impact everything else
downstream in the grass you can simulate
that using air flow a lot more easily
than you can a list of cron jobs so I
think that there's real potential there
for adopting this as a form of testing
data lineage as I mentioned several
times is a huge problem and actually air
flow already has some integration with
this it's not as well-documented it was
sort of just added but I expect to see
more people adopting it uses Apache
Atlas as the backend and this is gonna
become a huge deal for a lot of
companies once you start thinking about
GDP our compliance being able to
understand what data needs to even be
revoked how do you know what your
transformations are producing and where
that actually is going that's going to
be a huge need for a lot of companies
and have that baked into your execution
system is going to be very powerful so I
think that's a very compelling feature
for airflow alright now it's time to
talk about one of my passions graph
theory so you already have all this cool
stuff in a graph graphs are great air
flow is not doing anything with graphs
other than scheduling so what other
stuff could he do on graphs
whoa you could run algorithms on those
graphs like I just mentioned you could
do some sensitivity analysis what
happens if one of the nodes is disturbed
what happens to the downstreams of that
graph one thing I'm really interested in
is can you take an airflow dag can you
take a get branch of that dag and
understand the diff and actually found
some pretty promising algorithms for
this like being able to understand what
branch of the dag is considered new and
being able to spin up a testing
environment that just tests that code or
that understands that in this PR you're
adding this new set of dependencies to
these features again this is something
that airflow doesn't directly address
right now but all the building blocks
are there so I think there's like really
healthy room for development so I want
to thank you all for coming to this and
I think we have a little bit of time for
questions like a minute or two
[Music]
yeah so we have two systems for doing
this one is the legacy one where we
essentially just have like a folder that
has all of our dag so like a flat list
and that's fine
we deploy off of that repository it can
embed other Python like helper functions
if you need to though that's sort of
preferred to put that into a more
composable library and that's like a
fine approach it sounds pretty close to
what you're doing what I've really liked
is the approach that we've added for
that
quanto P and alpha model project where
we have a new repository that's all
based around like docker file builds and
it has a concept of here's the subfolder
for one particular project the related
DAGs for that project and any of the
container builds that are specific to
that project I do think it's a good
pattern to keep all this in a single
repository to the extent possible rather
than doing something like importing dag
code from the service that you're
managing with the dag code I think
centralizing it is good it helps with
more complex pull requests to be able to
pull requests against multiple DAGs in
one go
because even if you split things into
DAGs they often have relationships
between each other because they use
common resources but I think that the
way you're doing it it seems fine the
one caveat I add we haven't found any
benefit to putting it as a Python like
installable library as opposed to just
copying the files I think that that has
actually added some challenges for us is
making the dag itself be an installable
Python package gotcha thank you yeah can
you can you talk a little more about the
compare and contrast between airflow and
things like pachyderm because you know
one of them were kind of a more advanced
use cases for air flow that you talked
about that especially those that deal
with data that makes it look more like
pachyderm yeah so I did evaluate
pachyderm I didn't get much hands-on
experience with it but it was one of the
like 15 or so tools that I compared for
ETL services and it looked like a pretty
cool tool for if you're like an
individual
engineer working on a data science
project but it's very heavily based on
file system concept of moving data
around
it's very oriented towards a machine
learning use case almost everything that
we're showing you there is not machine
learning or it's a constrained machine
learning project that doesn't need to be
run on that kind of like pipeline so I'd
say it's actually fine to have separate
tools there it might make sense to use
something like pachyderm when you're
developing a project but the options for
taking that and running in the cloud on
a nightly basis and having a different
team run it they were not as compelling
some of the paid features look like they
might approach that but we didn't want
this to be something where you are
running these tasks on someone else's
servers we wanted an entirely self
hosted and overall airflow is very
oriented around that use case so we
wanted to choose something that was a
good fit rather than taking something
was good for the initial development
experience and focusing on that because
most of the time that a pipeline runs
it's not under development usually they
do eventually get to a steady state and
it's managing the complexity of
maintaining that number of pipelines
with small incremental changes that's
actually very challenging these people
will tend to forget what pipelines even
exist or what data dependencies exist so
it's sort of a very different use case
in that regard
also I have heard some very bad stories
about the Moore file system backed tools
like this one example with Luigi I saw a
presentation about that where they
described one data issued they'd had
where they waited for tasks to run based
on the existence of some folder that
gets produced by the previous task and
that sounds good except that the
previous task produced the folder before
it produced any files in the folder and
because it's such a file oriented notion
of task completion in Luigi it
immediately ran the next step with a
blank folder and like ended up
corrupting production data that's the
kind of thing that's very scary to me as
an operator I don't want anything that
assumes that the files exist on the file
system that that instance has been
running previously that has packages
installed
I want everything like that expressed in
containers and expressed in
understandable data definitions yeah oh
no time okay sorry
I will be out there if you want to ask
me questions later like lunchtime or so
thank you
[Applause]